you are uh
in my opinion probably the most infamous
slapper in hip-hop
when i think of uh
just rappers getting slapped or checked
i just think of mayno and obi in oh
eight are you i mean
and god
um how would we rate the will smith slap
that was a nice slap
that wasn't but i looked at it close
i don't think his palm connected
it almost like he held back a bit i
don't know if he held back but what
happened was that
he went up so he went up
high right and
chris rock rolled with it
so i think when he when he when he was
moving his face like that i i feel like
he missed the palm because i saw it in
slow motion
and i felt like his fingers
caught him
i don't know if he caught the whole um
like that right because if you i mean it
probably would have been because chris
took it like a champ but he like you
said i don't think he got because if you
get hit with that palm palm is the palm
that palm is different it's different
the palm is different when you catch him
with that with palmer and father his
daughters is different palma in five
it's different all right palmer father
his daughters
is different
it's
so i don't know if he caught that i
think he caught just i looked at the uh
the slow motion of it
when you uh i mean obviously when i
first saw it i was like i cuz i saw
carter caught alive i was like
i didn't yeah i didn't thought i was
getting lost i thought it was a bit or
something
i thought it was fake me too but then i
but then the second time he started
screaming and you could hear his voice
cracking i'm like oh no that's that's
what i know it was real yeah because he
smacked him and then he talked down to
him
right so he smacked him walked away
the smack looked fake
right right because i'm looking at it on
instagram
when he got when when the footage came
out of of what he said afterwards is
when we really knew it was real when he
was like
keep
my wife's name out your mouth no we've
all heard people we've all screamed like
that at somebody yeah that's that's when
you tie it yeah that's when you tie it
that's when you fed up enough's enough
enough's enough that's when you fed up
with a lot of [ __ ] and just like man
like
i'm tired of you i'm tired of playing
with you [ __ ] keep my [ __ ] wife's
name out your [ __ ] mouth period it's
almost like chris rock just wore
everybody's all the memes from the last
few years all the people making jokes
it's like chris chris wat he just held
the the the the blood of all of that
i love chris rock chris rock actually
one of my favorites as far as comedians
is concerned he's like in my top two
actually yeah to me it's him and
chappelle stand up wise stand up i'm
someone strictly stand up he's like one
of my he's like one of my he's like he's
one of them right for me
so
man
i don't know if he would i don't know if
it was
a lot of stuff that
will's been dealing with because listen
let's keep it real man in like life
people got this thing about celebrities
where they feel like
celebrities aren't as human as other
people of course and
people dealing with [ __ ] man everyday
life [ __ ] ups downs
you know on your quest to chase after
your dreams and
on your quest to conquer
conquer other other other goals
there's a lot that you dealing with man
family issues um
you know uh expectation issues you know
of other people so it's a lot then you
got to deal with we living in a time
where
we didn't we didn't used to hear
the opinions of everyone of everybody
right
social media made everybody accessible
to is like
you can't turn the noise off
as soon as you open your phone there's
an opinion about you mm-hmm as soon as
you so and the phone has
the phone is is your
it's your everything
so to speak because this is where you
find your media this is where you find
your news this is where you find
everything you want to you want to see
what the weather is like you got to
check your phone check your phone most
people don't have watches anymore they
got to not they got an apple watch
nobody's even worried about
what the what the watch say right right
so
as soon as you open up your phone
there's an opinion about you there's a
statement there's a thought
there's a
there's a uh uh
a criticism
there's a joke there's whatever
and people
artists celebrities
or what have you on any level
have to deal with that
and it's like
i have to have a
thick face black heart mentality and not
allow certain things
to ruffle my feathers
but sometimes at some point
people become human and they're not in
the move to play
you understand so
i'm not one of them [ __ ] that that
feel like
oh
you shouldn't handle problems with
violence i don't believe in
that i believe that
there's a there's a time and a place
for everything
and i believe i mean we're being like in
a country that was built on violence
don't preach to us now about right
violence when this is
the whole culture of this country
in its inception and what went on here
for
thousands
hundreds of years right not thousands
hundreds of years
and
i don't i don't think like i'm not here
to like say oh he's wrong for
handling his business maybe he should
maybe shouldn't have been there or
whatever but when you're in your mode
you're in your mode and how you feel is
how you feel
as a man now as a man you feel
disrespected in however you want to deal
with that disrespect
is
solely
up to you period point blank yeah i
would say like you can't tell people how
to react to this right that's the thing
people got a problem with that [ __ ] say
uh
some some slick [ __ ] to you
and then you go crazy on them
and then he'll say
it ain't that serious
[ __ ] it's not that serious to you right
but it's
optimum serious to me
this is maximum serious to me what you
care about is different than what i care
about your lines
your principles your code is different
than mines so
don't tell me
it's not that serious and oh you had to
do all that [ __ ] right
so that's the thing that's the
difference and you know that's that's
people i mean you know they just you you
somebody would disrespect you and then
tell you you shouldn't have
handled them
you meet disrespect with what with
disrespect right i mean at least
i mean obviously like you said it i
guess it's a subjective thing depending
on
some people
can take [ __ ]
a certain way or or or be the bigger
person but at the same time right at the
same time and then here's the thing on
the flip side to that is
people say was the joke that's serious
i understood the joke now it's like okay
here's the thing
if jada is really having a what they say
she has a
condition
with her yeah she's not she's not losing
her hair
because she wants to cut it off she cuts
it off because she what has to or or
whatever i would say you don't make fun
of people for things they can't change
right so that's something
you know that's a little bit more deeper
because that's a medical condition and
then you know you could tell like so
many people like like i just listened to
comments like oh well he was uh he was
laughing what happened yo laughing
sometimes
is a is a defense mechanism you ever
seen somebody so mad that they laugh
like
it's a scary scary uh yeah
like that's different
sometimes you
you you you don't know what nothing else
to do but laugh
in in in
the most disrespectful situations a
[ __ ] just like
word but in your in your mind and in
your heart you saying
i'm gonna burn this [ __ ] like that's
what you're saying like you know
it's crazy